democrat-run States cooking up even more
crazy ideas to ruin their cities and
cause residents and businesses to flee a
new bill in Oregon would decriminalize
camping in public places and let the
homeless treat their tents as private
homes even if they clog up the sidewalks
bakrants can even sue for up to one
thousand dollars if they are told to
relocate or are harassed
um Greg homelessness is a tough problem
but in Oregon they've spent millions of
dollars tens of millions and it's only
gotten worse with all the programs
they've implemented I love that they
call it right to rest everything now is
about it's right redistribution so your
right to walk your street safely is gone
but they can shoot up on your lawn and
no they aren't resting I know that we've
been fed alive at all the homeless are
out there and they're all victims it's
not true a lot of them are mentally ill
but a lot of them flock there to do
their drugs they harass locals they
publicly defecate they feed they thieve
is that a verb they thieve I should say
they steal they steal to pay for their
drugs so we're in a place where the
concept of Rights has been hijacked
corrupted and exploited and and the
worst of society is now getting to be
the benefit of it parents you're losing
your rights small businesses you lose
your rights police usual rights
meanwhile deranged Street people uh
professional professional thieves and
violent felons get more rights this is a
downward Trend it's only going in One
Direction you got to ask crime education
civility everything is tracking downward
it's so strange why is that it's going
from order to disorder and what's the
perfect example of disorder junkies and
criminals living on the street but if
you look at biology Justice the
classroom all of these Trends are going
towards a breakdown and it has to do
with a culture that deems structure and
Norms is evil in all of these situations
we're moving away Norm towards chaos
away from Norms so judge you know the
people who Implement these policies
would say that we're doing it to
decrease the homelessness problem but
for the ninth straight year in Oregon
the homeless population has grown yeah
well Oregon I I've come to the
conclusion on that you know there's a
lot that they don't understand I mean
didn't they have that that situation
where they were going to allow everyone
to shoot off but nobody would be
arrested and now they can't understand
why there's more crime and more drugs in
the area where they allow this open-air
drug use
uh here's the bottom line they that
their right to rest law which is
decriminalizing a camping in public
places is a total surrender of the rest
of our rights what is a public place a
public place is a sidewalk where can a
sidewalk be a sidewalk can be in front
of your home a sidewalk can be in front
of your business and if you dare sweep
harass or threaten them to move you'll
be fined a thousand dollars now I want
everyone to think about the fact that
where you live there are ordinances in
every city town and and Village and all
the municipalities you can build your
home or a wall or a fence unless it's X
feet from the street you know you will
be fined if you don't build in
accordance with the town ordinance these
people however they not only get to
violate all those ordinances that you
and I have to follow but they get to
impinge on your right to the enjoyment
of the use of your own property if I
like property and I paid a lot of taxes
I don't want to know that someone is on
a sidewalk and by the way if I'm a home
homeowner I have to maintain that
sidewalk and if I don't I'll be fined
right so it's almost like the government
coming in and using eminent domain that
in that that where they have to actually
reimburse you for the use of your
product uh your property you're taking
of your property they can block The View
they can block the space but then they
have to pay for it they can destroy your
business people aren't going to come in
where people are doing drugs fornicating
defecating and they think let me walk by
them so I can go into that store and buy
some shoes no yeah this is the
destruction of Law and Order and it is
it is stupid and for Oregon to continue
to do this is not only an impingement on
everyone else's right but it's
recognizing that they have no idea how
to handle this issue of homelessness
yeah Jessica the enabling of this
behavior and it's not just the the
camping but also they're allowing
squatters to take over private property
that is owned by folks they are allowing
the rights of law-abiding citizens to be
infringed upon for the sake of homeless
rights it's an incredibly tough issue
because to Greg's Point obviously there
are some bad actors in this but there
are a lot of people who are just have
fallen an incredibly tough circumstances
and are just trying to make it through
the night right that's not good but
you're not saying yeah I'm talking about
homelessness
it's not even writ large anymore we
understand it we look in the streets
these are people that are pretty much
happy with the situation I see a lot of
very unhappy people I take this you know
what I mean you mean the overwhelming
majority of people are drug addicts or
mentally ill meaning they prefer to when
I say mentally ill they're happy on the
street it's the same thing
it's the same thing okay
so Oregon is not the first state to do
this Colorado did it and
routine and they're actually usually
agreed upon as a pretty well-managed
state they're libertarian minded and it
shows that yes to some degree they don't
know what to do about the problem but
that also we do have an issue with
homeless people for instance being
attacked that story about the former San
Francisco Fire Chief where it was
supposed that the the 24 year old
homeless man beat him with a metal pipe
and now there's more surveillance
footage that he instigated it sprayed
him with bear spray and now we know that
there are up to eight separate incidents
where he went after homeless people okay
so the harassment is justification for
attempted murder
it was marketed as unprovoked assault
with a metal pipe and this you don't
have to Market it to me you spray
somebody and then you command me with a
question and why did he spray the other
eight people for I'm just saying that
homeless people are not living large and
not endangered you can't build a trend
around one Church you may be a jerk that
guy may be a jerk you might be
absolutely undoubtedly addressed but I
mean what you're trying to do is you're
trying to say okay ignore all of these
homeless guys in New York City that have
pushed Asian women in front of trains
have cold people no but you're
trying to you're trying to prop up one
thing that happened once and saying like
hey everybody it's not a problem look
what it's a they're the victims I'm
trying to tell you the problem
anyone hanging out on my steps there you
go and as a gun owner that's pretty good
that's a pretty middle of the road
answer there here's the deal buy
yourself a double wide in the middle of
the biggest piece of property you can
find get away from this concrete
Abomination let them all turn into
Chernobyl leave them to the mutants
willing to live here in the ruins go be
somebody don't live around this trash
that's all it's turning into and the
politicians will make sure it gets there
have pity if you want to but have pity
from a very far distance put it in the
middle of 20 acres and then when they
come on your property in state like
Georgia you give them a warning then a
warning shot well that's a great
solution I'm moving all right I want to
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now